berlin's police heritage collection
highlights a fascinating chapter the
city's turbulent past from the end of
World War two until the fall of the
berlin wall in 1989 the city was divided
into a division also reflected by the
east and west police forces former
officers have acquired and restored
these pieces of history on wheels the
collection reflects nearly a hundred
years of police heritage a good way to
keep the vehicles in working order is to
keep the movie this personnel carrier is
a 1955 Mercedes 311 used by the West
Berlin police until the 1970s the truck
engineering of the time was robust and
easy to learn even for today's drivers
this is excellent mas explains that this
is a straight-6 diesel engine
recognizable by the fuel injection
system and the fuel filter the six
cylinders put out 90 horsepower
lunch-ish piss the interior is purely
utilitarian the fuel tank inlet is
hidden under the passenger seat the
collection has two MW 240 dash tues the
successor the BMW 326 they were built in
Eisenach east germany in 1954 the
6-cylinder almost 2 litre engine made 57
horsepower former eisenach police
officers keep the village east german
police vehicle ruling so that it gathers
no moss
the police heritage collections VW bug
patrol car is still in street cruising
condition when the shorts fed mice boast
that the 68 bug is the pride of the
collection it was the last VW Bug to be
acquired by the West Berlin police and
it was in service till the mid-1970s
tell you all about having up on its
height the chase is a police show staple
and real-life criminals do try to get
hold of fast getaway cars thus it when
traction Avant even gained a reputation
as a gangster mobile its engine wasn't
the most powerful but its advanced
front-wheel drive gave the traction
Avant downright sensational handling for
the day word quickly got around in
criminal circles
police chase cars of the time often got
left in the dust the Ford eiffels
4-cylinder 1.2 liter engine only managed
37 horsepower the collection acquired
one a few years ago the estimates patmos
explains that the police cars of the
1920s 30s and on into the 50s generally
did not have revolving blue or red
lights like we know today this signaling
device was an ordinary searchlight with
a blue filter on it sunda xenologist on
vine Atkins Nirmala zhushan vomited a
blond child the retired police officers
play cops and robbers in their vintage
patrol cars complete with blue lights
and old-school sirens just to recreate a
bit of automotive history